a Massachusetts family has spent more
than eight years looking for answers
after a police officer killed their son
dan Roy DJ Henry a student-athlete at
New York's Pace University was shot by
Officer Aaron Hef's during a night out
with friends has claims Henry tried to
run him over with his car
witnesses report tell a different story
in tomorrow night's 48 hour CBS News
special correspondent James Brown spoke
to DJ Henry's parents about their
mission to find the truth Dan and Angela
Henry had no idea this would be the last
game they would watch their son play DJ
was a junior playing football for Pace
University a joy a Pied Piper in the
neighborhood all of the kids loved him
in the early morning hours of October 17
2010 the Henry's were startled awake
with the devastating news that their son
was shot to death in his car
I remember just falling to my knees and
I said who would shoot him Dan called
the police and says he was floored by
what he says he was told that DJ was
trying to run over a police officer and
that Officer had to shoot him to stop
him something had to have happened if
that happened like what caused him to do
something that's so outside of his
character DJ was out celebrating with
his teammates when other patrons got
into a fight police say that DJ was
parked in a fire lane in front of a bar
and when he was asked to move he
allegedly sped towards officer Aaron
Hesse propelling him on the hood and
forcing him to shoot deejay this is
police dashcam video on the right is
officer Hess behind him is DJ lying in
the road he had been pulled from a car
and handcuffed I'd like somebody to tell
me what other alternative Aaron Hess had
on the hood of a moving vehicle
Aaron hisses lawyer Bryan Sokolov other
than trying to save his own life or
closing his eyes and saying his prayer
this is cell phone video shot by a
bystander showing the chaos at the scene
we're in Wawa West that's what it felt
like
Desmond Hinds is one of DJ's friends who
was in the car that night
he says that Hess began shooting at them
unprovoked we weren't doing anything
wrong the henries decided to hire
acclaimed a civil rights attorney
Michael Sussman do you keep evidence
from every case that you handle I needed
it to be here so perhaps a day like
today would come when we could tell the
story what really happened here
despite the conflict officer Hess was
cleared of criminal wrongdoing and that
would propel the henries on a seven-year
journey to clear their son's name
we're not anti police were just trying
to understand what the facts tell us was
a a justified shooting or was it not
justified because if it wasn't it was
murder James Brown joins us from
Washington JB good to see you I'll be it
you know it was to better news and a
better story you talked about the family
spending seven years trying to find the
truth
how have their efforts paid off so
beyond uh it did in fact pay off for the
family it was a seven-year pursuit where
they exhausted every possible Avenue
again with the sole purpose of finding
out what the truth was this is a family
an all-american family a family of
character and integrity and a family of
deep faith and all they wanted to know
is what is the truth so that they could
have some resolution to this yes
you know JB we saw a DJ handcuff lying
on the ground after being shot the
question I have is did he receive any
kind of medical attention
Vlad his friends were in a car with him
and they said when he came to a stop
after being shot he commented to them
the police shot me they took DJ out of
the car handcuffed him laid him on the
ground and as you saw in that dashcam
video he was laying on the ground for
several minutes not having received any
medical aid at all well JB we will be
watching this thank you so much and you
can watch
JB's full report defending DJ on 48
hours tomorrow at 10:00 9:00 central
here on CBS